[Música]
hace ya unos cuantos años que la gran
mayoría de analistas Internacionales
sentenciaron que El dominio absoluto del
mundo por parte de Estados Unidos había
llegado a su fin aquel escenario que
resultó de la caída del muro de Berlín y
delfín de la unión soviética y que
alimentó a un mundo unipolar presidido
por el Tío Sam se desvaneció por
completo para muchos y la pregunta es
por qué pues por una razón muy simple
por el auge de un país que empezó a
plantarle cara a Estados Unidos y no
evidentemente no estamos hablando de una
Rusia renovada tras la caída de la unión
soviética sino del gigante asiático os
hablamos por supuesto de la República
popular China
[Música]
Y qué queréis que os diga no es para
menos al fin y al cabo hablamos de un
país que se ha convertido en la mayor
potencia industrial y la segunda mayor
economía de todo el planeta de hecho
china está mucho más cerca del Oro
estadounidense que del Bronce japonés
pero no se trata solo de una cuestión
económica china también es y lo es cada
vez más una importante potencia militar
de hecho exceptuando el tema nuclear
china Podría tener ya las segundas
fuerzas armadas con más capacidad de
todo el planeta Y claro con semejante
poder Industrial económico y militar el
fin del mundo Bipolar no es que parezca
cantado es que es ya un hecho Claro que
un momento porque mantener el ritmo de
Estados Unidos no resulta nada pero que
nada fácil y aunque china ha hecho unos
esfuerzos impresionantes muchos
analistas ya están señalando la fatiga
del gigante asiático especialmente
porque unas fuerzas armadas modernas y
grandes necesitan sobre todo una cosa
dinero muchísimo dinero y por eso hoy
aquí en visualpolitik nos hacemos unas
cuantas preguntas En qué situación se
encuentra China es posible que la
desaceleración e incluso la la crisis
frene su apuesta militar Cómo se está
fortaleciendo sabías por ejemplo que
china cuenta ya con la mayor fuerza
naval de todo el mundo que puede suponer
esto exactamente Pues bien respondamos a
todas estas preguntas vamos con ello
el Antiguo económico
durante décadas china desafiado toda
evidencia y previsión hasta convertirse
en la mayor autocracia y en un régimen
autoritario con bastante éxito si en su
día se pensó que el desarrollo traería
consigo una mayor apertura y mayores
niveles de libertad los hechos han
demostrado que esa tesis no era correcta
desde los años 70 con las reformas
económicas y políticas aperturistas de
tensión y gracias a sus abundantes
recursos demográficos energéticos e
hídricos china consiguió sacar a 800
millones de personas de la pobreza y
crecer un 10% anual hasta el final del
mandato de huintao en 2012 sin embargo
desde la llegada de Silvina al poder y
sobre todo en los últimos años china
empezado a tomar otro camino muy
diferente
[Música]
desde la llegada de silvin a la
presidencia algunas de las medidas que
auparon a la República Popular de China
el podio mundial han sufrido un
importante revés
ha involucionado hacia formas mucho más
autoritarias e intervencionistas ha
fortalecido de vigilancia del Estado ha
dado prioridad a las empresas públicas
lo que ha incluido regar de grandes
cantidades de capital a muchas de las
empresas estatales zombies además hay
que tener en cuenta que la china de
China no cuenta con las ventajas con las
que contaron sus predecesores los costes
salariales han crecido el mercado
inmobiliario está saturado el país cada
vez está importando más energía y la
población china está envejeciendo y
contrayéndose para 2050 las estimaciones
apuntan a que 700 millones de
trabajadores deberán mantener a 500
millones de pensionistas 300 millones
más que en la actualidad
por eso no es de extrañar que china ya
no esté presentando un crecimiento como
el que tenía antes de la llegada de
sillín de hecho es aún peor
desde la crisis del 2008 el crecimiento
económico de China prácticamente no ha
dejado de caer si no ha logrado frenar
la desaceleración de la economía China y
eso a pesar de que ha utilizado enormes
paquetes de gasto público para intentar
conseguirlo y ojo porque no se trata
solo de eso tal y como ya os hemos
comentado un montón de veces en nuestro
boletín de patreon las claves de la
semana la economía china se está
enfrentando a muchísimos problemas por
cierto si os gusta lo que hacemos
queréis ayudarnos a crecer y a seguir
mejorando podéis uniros a la comunidad
de visualpolitik de patrón en patrón.com
visualpolitik además por muy poco
podréis recibir un montón de contenido
extra y también regalos exclusivos os
dejo toda la info en la descripción un
millón de gracias a todos los que ya
formáis parte de la comunidad de
visualpolitik en patreon pero hecho este
apunte si hablamos de problemas en China
Tenemos que tener en cuenta también este
dato fijaos la deuda de china en
relación con el pib aumenta hasta un
récord del
279,7% por el auge del crédito a esto se
le une el cierre de 4,4 millones de
negocios que se vieron obligados a
cerrar debido a la dura política de la
covid cero y aunque Es verdad que el
desempleo Aparentemente ha caído del 5,3
al 5,2%, la realidad es que el desempleo
juvenil se situó por encima del 21% en
junio de 2023 y lo cierto Es que en
general las previsiones económicas sobre
china se están revisando a la baja en
comparación con periodos anteriores de
su historia
por ejemplo goldman sachs que previó que
la economía china superaría en 2026 el
americana y que para 2050 superbé sería
el doble que el del Tío Sam tuvo que
revisar en 2022 sus previsiones entonces
predijo que china superaría Estados
Unidos en 2035 y que como mucho
superaría solo en un 15% al pib
estadounidense Y la verdad hoy quizás
sean todavía menos optimistas de hecho
cada vez son más los analistas que ponen
en cuestión que china logre siquiera
alcanzar a Estados Unidos y eso hablando
en términos de pib absoluto sin tener
nada más en cuenta y ojo porque no Esto
no es una declaración anti china ni nada
por el estilo todo lo contrario en
visualpolitik hemos celebrado y contado
los grandes avances cosechados por este
país un país que en líneas generales
pensamos que ha tenido una contribución
muy positiva para todo el mundo en las
últimas cuatro décadas sin embargo El
problema es que desde hace unos años
también nos venimos contando que las
cosas tanto desde el punto de vista
económico como político se están
deteriorando O al menos que están
dejando de ir también os hablamos de
ello hace un par de años y eso
exactamente lo que está ocurriendo
porque amigos Más allá de la propaganda
los datos están sobre la mesa Claro que
un momento porque quizás muchos
consideréis que el hecho de que el
gigante asiático quizás no supere
económicamente Estados Unidos es una
excelente noticia sin embargo sabéis que
muchos de los analistas que hacen este
pronóstico también defienden que esto
puede suponer un grave peligro Pero cómo
es eso posible no se supone que lo más
peligroso sería lo contrario pues
atentos
[Música]
la gran Marina China
estoy seguro de que muchos habréis
escuchado estos últimos años y la ugel
de China podría poner en serios aprietos
a Estados Unidos incluso ha habido
algunos reputados analistas como graham
Allison de la Universidad de Harvard
quien ha apuntado a que la uge de China
y la consecuente caída de Estados Unidos
llevaría a una guerra Inevitable sin
embargo Viendo la situación actual de
China y sus cada vez más pobres
proyecciones de crecimiento muchos
analistas ahora ya están empezando a
dejar de lado la teoría de Allison hoy
estos analistas han empezado a abrazar
otra teoría una que dice que china está
llegando a su punto álgido el cual
seguirá estando por debajo de Estados
Unidos y que una vez que llegue a ese
punto empezará el declive del país pues
bien es este escenario según ellos el
verdaderamente preocupante para Estados
Unidos y para el resto del mundo por qué
pues por una simple razón porque al
igual que en el animal más peligroso que
el que está herido no hay país más
peligroso que el que están declive
cuando para intentar evitar su caída no
pocas veces recurren a la violencia y la
pregunta es sabéis que ha estado
haciendo china todos estos años pues
fijaos
efectivamente ha estado incrementando su
presupuesto en defensa un 9% anual desde
que se puso en marcha la modernización
del ejército anunciaba en los años 90 de
esta forma china llegaba a tener un
presupuesto militar de
224.000 millones de dólares para el 2023
el segundo más grande de todo el planeta
con todo ese dinero china ha estado
modernizando progresivamente sus
capacidades e instalaciones militares
por ejemplo hoy este país cuenta ya con
1700 aviones de combate entre los que
encontramos incluso aviones de quinta
generación como el j20 y otros
comparables con los f-16 o f-18 de
Estados Unidos y de hecho se habla poco
de ello pero china cuenta ya con la
mayor fuerza aérea de toda Asia sin
embargo adivináis en qué rama de las
fuerzas armadas ha concentrado la mayor
inversión 3 2 1 porque sí lo habéis
adivinado en la marina
la modernización naval de China comenzó
en los años 90 ya ha conseguido que la
Marina china se convierta en la más
grande del mundo al menos el número con
351 navíos en 2022 por encima incluso de
la estadounidense que contó con 294
embarcaciones ese mismo año además no
solo cuenta con más naves sino que las
capacidades de estas también han
mejorado sustancialmente desde los 90
entre otras cosas Gracias a la inclusión
de misiles balísticos y de crucero
antibuque entre otros muchos equipos y
no solo eso china también cuenta con una
gran flota de submarinos Destructores y
cruceros es más incluso ha conseguido
establecerse como la segunda potencia
con más portaaviones en 2012 y en 2019
presentó sus dos primeros y en 2022
presentó su tercer portaaviones el
fuchen un buque que ya cuenta con
capacidades como el uso de catapultas Un
diseño electromagnético usado para
lanzamiento de jets
ahora bien creéis que con esta gran
flota china podría derrotar a la marina
norteamericana Pues por el momento no no
parece que ese sea el caso veréis es
cierto que China tiene una mayor
cantidad de navíos militares y de hecho
se espera que para el 2030 submarina sea
Incluso un 50% más grande que la de
Estados Unidos pero la realidad queridos
amigos de visualpolitik es que aunque El
Tío Sam cuente con menos navíos los
suyos son más grandes completos y
capaces
[Música]
por ejemplo en comparación con los
portaaviones chinos los estadounidenses
son mucho más grandes están propulsados
por energía nuclear lo que evidentemente
les da mayor autonomía y pueden embarcar
y operar un mayor número de aviones
desde uno de estos portaaviones Estados
Unidos prácticamente puede desencadenar
toda una guerra además tened en cuenta
que la potencia norteamericana cuenta
con más embarcaciones cruciales a nivel
militar como portaaviones cruceros o
Destructores lo que les daría una Clara
ventaja en un escenario de guerra no
obstante independientemente de si china
está cerca o no de alcanzar su pico y
comenzar a caer lo que está claro es que
el gigante asiático se ha convertido en
una potencia militar Y sobre todo naval
formidable de eso no cabe duda Pero por
qué tanta inversión en la Marina Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
una partida de
muchos han intentado descubrir Cuál
sería la estrategia de China para poder
convertirse en una superpotencia capaz
de hacerle frente a Estados Unidos y la
mayoría han concluido que todo pasa por
una región El dominio del mar de la
China meridional si china se hiciera con
el control total de esta región todo
apunta que ya podríamos estar hablando
de una superpotencia a nivel del Tío Sam
y es que veréis en este mar hay unas
reservas probadas de 11.000 millones de
barriles de petróleo y a un mucho más de
gas natural pero lo verdaderamente
importante de este mar es la enorme
ventaja que estratégica que le
proporcionaría al contendiente que
lograron hacerse con su control y en
este caso el mayor contendiente es China
el fortalecimiento naval de China se
explica por su ambición de convertirse
en una potencia mundial con capacidad
para moldear el orden internacional pero
también para asegurar y proteger sus
rutas comerciales marítimas ya que el
80% de las operaciones comerciales
chinas se llevan a cabo por esta vía por
eso china no ha dudado en pasar por
encima del derecho internacional y
establecer la famosa línea de los nueve
puntos para intentar reducir el riesgo
de que se produzca un corte de
suministro de bienes estratégicos Como
por ejemplo el petróleo como recordaréis
la línea de los nueve puntos es el
territorio que china reclama como
soberano Pese a que interfiere con las
zonas económicas exclusivas de vecinos
como filipinas Vietnam Malasia o brunei
Pues bien dentro de esta línea reclamada
por china se encuentran Islas que sus
vecinos también reclaman como las de los
archipiélagos de las Islas spratly o
paracell Islas que china ha tomado por
la fuerza y que ha militarizado y
expandido inicialmente
sin embargo la razón principal O al
menos la más comentada en general no es
esta sino la intención china ha de
invadir Próximamente la isla de formosa
es decir Taiwán China prevé la
unificación armada con Taiwán para 2027
académico clave el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de Taiwán advierte de un
conflicto con china en 2027 este es
seguramente el mayor punto de tensión
entre Washington y Pekín entre otras
cosas y chips aparte porque Taiwán sirve
como una barrera que evita que china
tenga vía libre para expandirse hacia el
lindo Pacífico precisamente por eso
actualmente china está invirtiendo
tantos recursos en su marina
Piénsalo bien si china se lanzara a
tomar todo el mar de la china meridional
incluido Taiwán Estados Unidos tendría
menos capacidad de actuación teniendo en
cuenta que sus aviones de combate se
encuentran a más de 1000 kilómetros en
okinaway y en one además china podría
desplegar aviones de combate en las
islas que ha estado ocupando desde sus
cuatro bases aéreas localizadas en este
mar y no solo eso el gigante asiático ha
establecido también un fuerte sistema de
radares en estas Islas y además cuenta
con un mayor número de misiles en la
región pero sea como sea la pregunta es
creéis de verdad que sería tan fácil
derrotar a Estados Unidos como os podéis
imaginar Esto es algo más bien
improbable no solo porque la potencia
norteamericana tenga mucha más
experiencia reciente en guerras y unos
navíos más avanzados sino también porque
como apuntan muchos analistas chinos
para poder tener éxito en un conflicto
de tal naturaleza este país tendría que
resolver primero algunos inconvenientes
hablamos de detalles como el suministro
de armas a Taiwán desde Estados Unidos
la inexistencia de un plan frente a las
sanciones que Seguro seguro le serían
impuestas o la incapacidad actual de
tomar de manera extremadamente rápida da
igual entre otras muchas posibilidades
así queridos amigos de visualpolitik ya
lo veis son ya muchos los analistas que
vaticinan la llegada del tope de
crecimiento de China Claro que esto
lejos de acabar con las aspiraciones de
Pekín de dominar por completo el mar de
la China meridional y plantarle cara a
Estados Unidos como una superpotencia
las puede incluso reforzar sin pin ya ha
conseguido que china tenga la mayor
flota naval militar de todo el mundo
Ahora solo nos queda hacernos algunas
preguntas cuándo mostrará Pekín toda su
capacidad naval al resto del mundo será
verdad que china no alcanzará a Estados
Unidos como primera potencia mundial
podéis dejarnos como siempre vuestras
impresiones en los comentarios y así
abrir debate y ahora si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like suscribiros al politic si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho y ya sabéis si os
gusta lo que hacemos también podéis
echarnos una mano en patreon.com visual
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]